[Music]
so Mike you finished a co2 see the
weekend I have been playing and really
enjoying it we're gonna compare it this
week to Assassin's Creed origins which
came out last year these two games very
different departures to what we know and
love of old Assassin's Creed games it
definitely feels like Odyssey is
building on what origins started yeah so
do you think let's this will kick off
with the gameplay yeah so origins and
Odyssey are these like definitely the
biggest games in the series they're a
drastic departure from syndicate and
that the combats more deliberate it's
more focused on loot and progression
right I will say that in terms of that
Odyssey is a little bit too much for me
it is super bloated I like the idea of
the progression I like getting legendary
sets I like killing these cultists to
get like the Spartan war hero set or the
Athenian war hero set or Agamemnon's
Greaves etc but I do I do think origins
was in many ways but I guess we'll start
the progression was much more focused I
feel like they despite the game is being
developed at the same time I think
Odyssey does kind of emphasize the like
maybe too much of that bloat that I kind
of thought they were getting a little
too close with - with origins but I do
like that you know the games are kind of
they're not pure RPGs but they are based
more around progression so you can you
can explore wherever you want in the
world essentially right away but that's
not gonna that's not you know like
guaranteeing that you'll survive in
every area and I like that idea that
it's kind of like much more open-ended
than the rest of the series
I like you not to see how different
areas the map are very clearly gated for
what level you should be and I also
think that when I was playing origins I
found myself getting locked out of
quests because I was too under leveled
and having to do menial side tasks a
whole lot more whereas in Odyssey I feel
like I'm leveling up at a good pace and
also I prefer the way that in Odyssey
they've been doing like the RPG skill
unlocks is that you can respec at any
time
whereas in origins it's so difficult
because both the games have such a
similar names in origins you kind of
just picked skills and you were forced
to sort of run with them but saying that
in Odyssey it lets you respect but it
doesn't let you save specific loadouts
so there was like some specific boss
fights that I was doing that I had to
I've been speaking as an assassin like
it's a silent hunter and then I was
doing this boss fight I was like well I
can't use any of these skills and
they're completely pointless so we have
to respect but I have to remember what I
was spec does earlier and it just seems
like there needs to be a few quality of
life adjustments but I feel like it's a
definite improvement on origins yeah and
if you want to get more into the combat
outside the progression I think I like
origins more looking back on it because
of how it still kind of balances that
all the SAS ins crew feel the games were
never realistic at all what you're
punching the Pope at the end of
Assassin's Creed 2 they were still sort
of rooted in physics for the most part
and I think origins more so like
obviously you're a full-on demigod you
are warping to your spear what you throw
it to someone like like a watchtower
away you are doing a ground pound
there's no I mean there's falling damage
at first but then like when you get high
on there's no falling damage you can
never die from falling and that's fine
because you are they're paying you to
beat this demigod there it's more of a
superhero game I like the origins cuz it
did feel more grounded you felt like you
were a human you're this Magi like this
Egyptian policeman that was kind of
helping out or forming the assess and
slowly a little by little but I liked
that I still felt kind of weak in this
world and I know the point of Odyssey is
to be this like overpowered demigod
toward the end but I liked origins
because I still felt like this assassin
but I did feel that also that like
stealth is the thing that neither game
really [ __ ] yeah because I mean and you
have been working on a feature about
this old Assassin's Creed games totally
focused on the south and you could you
felt like an assassin going through
slipping through crowds and killing
people whereas in this one I can hit
assassinate on someone and it won't kill
him yeah and it's super annoying and I
feel that if I accidentally get spotted
there's less leniency on you know being
able to slip back into stealth and
everything just completely disintegrates
around me I don't know I think I prefer
weirdly like old Assassin's Creed games
for that yeah I agree
it's it kind of abandoned what the
series used to have in terms of stealth
but I still think because of the way I
felt so like vulnerable in origins it
did feel like I was more pushed towards
stealth even though the combat still
like drove me toward being a warrior in
the end and they both have naval combat
I think I prefer well I don't know
because I go through two mines but right
I don't go out of my way to do the naval
combat stuff it's just there but while
I'm doing it it's kind of fun
I actually think Odyssey has the edge
because it's integral to the world it
makes sense it's the Aegean Sea it's you
know it is an odyssey you have a ship in
origins it's this tangential thing
you're playing as aya who was a great
character that's like these not
flashbacks but these side stories that
are kind of you know like cursory of
like when it comes to the whole plot but
yeah I do think origins one of the large
reasons I think it is the better game in
general and a better Assassin's Creed
game especially is because it doesn't
have that bloat right there's not like
the merciless mercenary system I think
the game Odyssey could have done without
I mean it's its nemesis light and that
even that is kind of giving it too much
credit I do like the cult system I like
that that was like kind of this this
through thread through the main plot the
side quest each island you go to might
be connected to different cultists I
think that's the thing as well that ties
into Cassandra and Alexios being
mercenaries and not necessarily having
any particular ties to anyone and just
kind of flitting around and killing
whoever I mean we've talked about this
when you're going through you can be in
a Spartan camp or an Athenian camp and
you can just decide to kill icon if you
want yes never really create who you're
fighting well I guess that's part of
being mercenary is ya don't have to pick
side you just go with whoever's being
paid but I feel like that's the thing
that Assassin's Creed needs is cuz
you're always fighting for freedom
you're fighting for the assassin never
really clear in Odyssey who that is I
think the idea of being a mercenary
that's playing both sides is really cool
and like if you were actually a
mercenary and not like allied to one
side but I think it clashes with some of
Cassandras dialogue that you have to see
in cutscenes like it'll be like she's
really fighting for Sparta or cares
about Sparta but then again later on
you'll kill an entire camp of Spartans
so while I do like the idea that I think
Odyssey was going for I don't think it
works out all the time and I felt again
like that focus that origins has in
AIT's gameplay just makes it overall
less bloated and more refined game one
of the cool things that Assassin's Creed
games have always done is giving you
this great big historical sandbox to
play around in so in origins we had
Egypt's not ancient Egypt as a commenter
Ptolemaic Egypt
Tomek Egypt and in Odyssey we have
ancient Greece which did you prefer
which you think stood out long I like
Egypt I think they did a lot with what
could have been potentially boring
despite like how many cools you get to
see the Pyramids of Giza you get to see
you know like Alexandria and see the
library there's you know like I think as
we get farther into the Assassin's Creed
series the settings become even more
important because they did lose some of
those pillars that social stealth that
being an actual assassin so I think the
setting becomes all more important and I
know Egypt Japan and World War two were
those three most often fan-requested
settings and then I think was create a
director of three Alex Hutchinson's that
no those are boring he never really
substantiated that claim I think is just
a personal opinion but for them to take
Egypt one of the most requested settings
and just knock it out of the park like I
love that in the world of origins like
if I keep saying it feels more confident
but it feels like there's a willingness
to let you find your own story rather
than like just throwing these activities
at you well in terms of the actual
world design I like that you can there's
the big I think it's called the Katara
Depression in the middle of the map it's
just this barren desert and I think the
only point of interest you come it might
have one viewpoint and it's like the
center of the map and you really ride
across it and you're not getting just
barged with like exclamation points and
question marks you come across this like
old shipwreck from maybe when like I
don't know if the Nile overflowed into
that way back in the day and it's
confident enough to not even have
anything there maybe you'll run into an
animal maybe you'll see a cactus here
and there but that's it I could see why
people might think that's a waste of
space but I think that makes that space
even more meaningful I don't think that
aside from the empty sees that guess
which you know still you hear like the
your crew singing you hear Barnabas
talking to you and Odyssey I don't think
Odyssey had that same like patience to
just let you move through its world
without throwing something at you yeah
kind of like the fear that the player
would bounce off it if it didn't hear
and have something immediately I mean in
order sees defense I think what they did
with ancient Greece was great and I
really love what they've done and I love
the way that obviously they're basing it
on the real world but it's all these
distinct little islands with their own
little stories there are no people I
really enjoyed that when it came to
Odyssey origins I felt that you know so
you enjoyed the empty space and I felt
like it was just seeing how huge that
map was I'm seeing how he to map is in
Odyssey as well yes just a lot yeah too
much and it can feel over bearing and
maybe that's just a sign of Assassin's
Creed games as they stand right now but
I don't want to call my horse and then
just say okay follow the path to the
quest marker I'll just wait here and
check my phone for a minute while you do
that yeah I was a camel guy I always am
but then I like I I don't know I like I
do enjoy that so I think map wise
Odyssey is probably like double the size
of origin but landmass wise that you're
actually exploring on your feet is
roughly the same from what I understand
I'm sure like digital foundry or someone
we'll do an actual comparison or already
has and I just didn't do my research but
origins I think again I keep going back
to the fact that it just feels more
focused and refined I feel like it made
better use of its landmass more than
Odyssey again like I felt like do we
give you be soft [ __ ] all the time for
just having like their their maps are
these checklists and again I enjoyed
Odyssey because for doing all those
things I still have like half the quest
checked off out of the 70 hours I've
played but I feel like origins over the
course of however many hours it took me
to actually beat it 45 or something I
felt like it made better use of each
individual moment and the characters in
the world I like that I remember like
different farmers I was helping out and
it might have just been a fetch quest
but I kind of saw these slice-of-life
in a total make Egypt I just kind of
felt like origins stuck the landing a
bit better so you mentioned that
characters and the story you prefer
origins I take it yeah so obviously a
each assassin's creed is set during
these times of upheaval French
Revolution American Revolution that told
them like you know like Rome coming into
Egypt it's always time during times of
great change or whatever and I I do I I
think ah to see the Peloponnesian War is
like it's great for an assassin's Creed
game or just like a great time to
explore because after fighting off like
Xerxes in the Persian army Greece just
turns on itself and I like that and it's
cool how they show that the order is it
a cult of cosmos sorry orders origins
they're like pulling strings behind the
scenes but I felt like origins was
actually like a they they focused on it
because of its story I felt like the
Peloponnesian War just became an excuse
to have that war system after a while
and I felt like the family Odyssey the
Star Wars ish you know like well Greek
tragedy I guess of Odyssey became the
real story whereas the time period just
became less meaningful to me whereas
origins I don't think they could have
told that story without you know Julius
Caesar and Cleopatra coming into the
picture and like your side playing with
like taking down Ptolemy and actually at
one point helping Julius Caesar that I
felt like the the story made better use
of the historical characters than
Odyssey did yeah that makes sense but I
think I am preferring
I prefer the story of Odyssey more
because it is a more focused family
based affair because I felt like with
origins I mean by ik and aya story just
didn't click for me and I just I liked I
as a character but by ik just I think in
my heart of hearts I'm always kind of
hoping for another Ezio you want like a
one you you want an assassin who's wise
cracky who's funny
who's glib and you know Evie and Jacob
sort of you could tell they were going
for that it didn't mean it and and I
think I'm playing as Cassandra and I
love the way that she feels well-rounded
despite some inconsistencies in plot
mm-hmm just by the pure nature of being
immersed anyplace both sides but she I
just like the way that she feels more
well-rounded and I like the way that
it's her quest to find out what happened
to her family and that's what's driving
you through sure I don't think all the
gameplay stuff matches up and lives up
to that yeah but it for me it has to be
a character that I can latch on to and
by excitedly wasn't yeah I feel like
again origins for me the the characters
I have more characters that I remember
not names necessarily back
but I do feel like origins I have more
kind of like those side stories and
those those analog emerging kind of
anecdotes that I found in Egypt more
than I did in Odyssey maybe it was maybe
it was because Odyssey felt so focused
on pushing me into the mercenary system
or the occultist that I personally
wasn't investing as much and maybe that
was my fault
I'll admit and maybe because that were
there wasn't that bloated I was more
able to focus on the story in origins
and just kind of go at a measured pace
but I felt like it just like you know
parceled out these little stories these
slice-of-life things across you know
Ptolemaic Egypt a lot more
professionally that it did an odyssey I
say I don't know because I think the
sidequest content in Odyssey is a lot
better done sure there's just the plain
old fetch quests and things but you know
we all came in we were playing in at
work and we were talking about that
Randy old woman when we worry how good
we were to run into the moonlit forest
shed our clothes and pleasure each other
until sunrise our howls of ecstasy would
echo throughout the valleys God's woman
I said spare me the details and you know
you've got the weird romances that sure
they're not done to the level of like a
Bioware romance where you actually care
about the other character but they're
funny and that to me is that they're
more memorable for sure I will give you
that I think Assassin's Creed Odyssey
has the clear edge in like leaning into
the comedy the series has always been
very dumb when you really step back and
look at it
I think origins was to self-serious
sometimes especially byuk and aya as
much as I loved their relationship I
think byuk was just like he needed to
chill out every once in a while and also
stony-faced a whole
speaking of stone I don't know if
Florence had weed I'm talking you're
talking about stone chin I'm talking
about weed I didn't buy a key needs to
start smoking weed because he's way too
uptight sometimes or do something to
relax I don't know but I think Odyssey
is embraces its tone much better than
origins I will give you that but overall
I think story wise I care more about the
characters and origins I care more about
where it was going
I think it made better use of the
historical characters then Odyssey did
and overall I like the story in origins
much better so after all that discussion
I think it's pretty clear which game you
prefer I prefer origins overall I love
both of them they're very fun I think
origins is a better game I don't know I
personally really prefer Odyssey because
I think it just it takes a lighter tone
I'm more invested in the story sure
there's a lot of bloat but at the same
time I am still finding myself just kind
of going okay I'll do one more for I'll
do one more encampment I'll do one more
side quest which i didn't have with
origins it is the peak Ubisoft game and
they have clearly figured out how to
nail that and I like I think we like the
games for the same reasons but I think
like my love for origins just a little
bit outshines Odyssey yeah but let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below or come find us both on Twitter
I'm at least James games
I'm MMA hardy because that's what people
think it says what it's it's Emma Hardy
Amber's like are you a MMA fighter I was
like more clearly don't I look like one
sorry I didn't realize with your off the
whole thing no that's fine I'm Emma
Harvey I will see you next week for
another episode of business bye
[Music]